now I've seen this reaction lots of
times but this is the first time I've
seen it in high speed where we pour the
solution in quite slowly but then watch
what happens the reaction of copper with
ammonia is quite a well-known reaction
and often students school children come
across it quite early on in their career
it's a reaction which gives both a
precipitate and then a color change it
involves copper sulfate which in
solution is a fairly pale blue and you
can imagine in the solution you have
copper iron Cu 2 plus surrounded by six
water molecules further too close
together and to that a rather further
apart this does not absorb light very
strongly so the solution looks very pale
when you add ammonia which is alkaline
in when it's dissolved in water you
precipitate a pale blue solid which is a
mixture of copper hydroxide and copper
sulphate so called basic salt and then
as you add more ammonia this Reda's
all's to give a very intense blue color
the blue color is due to copper ions the
same copper ions but now with for
ammonia molecules interacting with it in
the tetrahedral shape this is a baby toy
that I got in Italy it's quite fun so
there aren't really jewels and cheese
attached to it no no no this is just
this pizza as well
so when the copper goes from this shape
that is quite pale colored to this one
that is tetrahedral the color comes much
more intense and it is a very nice
demonstration for people just beginning
chemistry to see how copper can form the
so called coordination complexes where
stable molecule like ammonia can
actually bind to the copper ions and
what I find quite surprising is if you
watch carefully it really goes blue dark
blue before you see the precipitate
whereas chemically it should be the
other way around you should see the
precipitate and then the dark blue color
and my only explanation and this may
well be wrong is that it takes time for
the precipitate to form crystals that
are big enough you to see when
crystallites are very small their size
is shorter than the wavelength of light
so they appear invisible though they can
still absorb light and then as they grow
bigger you see physical clumps of them
because they're much bigger than the
wavelength of light and this growing of
particles can be relatively slow
compared to the initial precipitation
which forms really tiny ones when you
look at at the end it looks rather
beautiful it looks very like the planet
Earth seen from space
you